reactions still coming in on former
raiders coach john gruden resigning
that's right and there's just so many
questions about where the raiders go
from here with their new head coach ron
fertrell joining us live here in studio
and ron what's next okay christian
kirsten a lot of people wondering that
right now a lot to uncover here reports
from nfl insiders say that the league is
not happy with raiders owner mark davis
right now and how this entire matter was
handled adam schefter reports that the
league wanted gruden to be disciplined
before sunday's game against the bears
now remember the first email came out
friday and when that didn't happen more
emails came out to the new york times
on monday in fact during monday night
football and of course everything blew
up then and gruden resigned this may
also speak to the bigger question right
now and that's the issue with the
raiders front office remember team
president mark bedan and three others
resigned over the summer there's still
no full-time president but look forward
to the raiders new head coach their
interim
head coach
rich basatia he did a great job coaching
special teams for the raiders he's been
coaching football for 40 years was with
the cowboys for for years and our cowboy
insider says raider fans will like what
they see in rich versace he's a he's a
really good guy
he's paid his dues
i know he's been looking for this
opportunity and i would imagine the
bottom line will be well how do the
raiders do uh in these final what 12 12
games of the season it's uh you know
it's almost like a long interview right
yes indeed still some questions about
john gruden's salary he still had six
years left on his contract at 10 million
dollars a year so was there a buyout did
he just walk away from 60 million
dollars
we may never know the answer to those
questions but also i do want to mention
tampa bay has announced that gruden's
name will be removed from their ring of
honor he won a super bowl with the bucks
in 2003 that was in fact against the
raiders at that time
and back to the raiders well they get to
work tomorrow with their new interim
head coach they play at denver on sunday
kirsten all right thank you for that
update ron